william vous êtes bien sûr dites nous
pourquoi donc moi je suis pour diminuer
la consommation de viande
si on part ya plein de raisons d'arrêter
de manger de la viande
si on parle de l'écologie à trois
raisons on a entendu parler cette année
des feux de forêt en amazonie de
l'amazonie en train de partir en fumée
c'est pourquoi parce que on veut raser
les arbres on veut les brûler pour
pouvoir ensuite planter du soja qui va
servir à alimenter les animaux le bétail
etc pour pouvoir manger de l'avion ces
animaux là ils sont alimentés on les
nourrit mais après c'est un énorme
gaspillage en fait puisque sûr je crois
que c'est sur 4 g de protéines y en a 1
g qui va sortir en protéines en
protéines animales du coup c'est un
énorme gaspillage
ensuite il ya le lisier en bretagne on a
entendu parler cette année je crois
qu'il ya au moins un enjeu d'excréments
d'animaux le lisier voilà le lisier
c'est pas le fumier donc le fut mais qui
est mélangé lui avec du foin qui permet
de se décomposer qui permet d'être
réutilisés en engrais le lisais c'est
juste de les excréments et la piste des
cochons qui est content qu'ils aient
gardé dans des cuves pour l'être dans
les élevages intensifs parce qu'ils
savent pas quoi en faire
garth a demandé qu après il étale tout
ça dans des champs ils jettent tous et
toutes et pendu dans des champs sa part
dans les rivières sa part dans la nappe
phréatique
ça se retrouve sur les plages l'eau kg
qui devrait être potable
moi j'avais vont prendre d'airbnb qu'on
fait des enquêtes en bretagne une fois
sur deux les jambes 10 bat attention il
faut pas boire d'eau parce que l'eau ya
trop nitrates dans l'eau elle est
polluée et après ils les plages la
moitié des plages bretonnes maintenant
sont fermés à cause des algues vertes
donc c'est le seul disait là qui vient
alimenter ces algues il ya des gens qui
sont morts de juste de marché dans ces
algues l'afp ça va ça va une fois qu'on
marche en fait on y berlinguez sulfurisé
il ya des gens qui sont morts les plages
sont fermées
là on est récemment elle est allée à
saint brieuc ils mettent des nets des
barrières en fait avec des panneaux pour
la plage est interdite d'accès ça c'est
la moitié des plages en bretagne et le
quatrième point c'était évidemment il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont entendu parler
que l'élevage est responsable de 14 5 %
des gaz à émission de des émissions à
effet de serre des gaz à effet de serre
voilà c'est ça et du coup c'est autant
qu'elle transporte donc on sait très
bien qu évidemment qu'on utilise sa
voiture ça pollue ondres utilisé -
l'avion m'en parle pas
mais du coup on se rend compte que le
bétail manger de la viande
ses responsables autant pour la
pollution que les transports laurent
seillier vous êtes là sur la soul est
con je suis assez surprise d'ailleurs
oui mais aussi ben ouais enfin je vous
parlais de beaucoup de choses monsieur
mais vous savez que chaque jour en
france il ya un agriculteur qui se
suicide ouais on a reçu ici vous savez
qu ami qui a perdu son mari qui s'est
suicidé
on annonce une nombreuse agriculteurs
lors des défilés jaune et qui souffre et
vraiment voilà qui souffrent beaucoup et
qui ont beaucoup beaucoup de ballons nos
éleveurs sont dans une situation en
france qui est dramatique
donc ça me fait beaucoup de peine que
sous prétexte d'écologie que je respecte
mais y'a plein de moyens de préserver
l'écologie autre que celui là on retombe
encore dans un agrès bashing totalement
insupportable parce que qu'est-ce que ça
mais d'hyères qui pâtit aujourd'hui de
cette nouvelle mode d'aller saccager les
boucheries critiquer les gens qui font
de l'élevage mais ce sont des français
qui travaillent qui travaille comme tout
le temps pour mourir la population
française alors qu'est ce qu'on va
manger à la place de la viande le fruit
d'accords monsieur n'est pas venu alors
là si un domaine que je connais c'est
que celle du tri sionisme agriculteurs
et vous expliquer une petite chose une
protéine animale pour la remplacer c'est
très compliqué si vous voulez remplacer
le bonnet cruciaux des végétariens
végétariens les bus des montées au
couscous boulet que
il m'a confirmé aujourd'hui je soutiens
toujours démonstration de ce que
michelle kwan il fait ce qu'il veut
après tout moi je suis plus préoccupé
par l'avenir des aides aux grands bras
voilà bravo et je sais qu'il est au
moins pour remplacer une protéine
animale il faut former une association
complexe de féculents et céréales et ça
c'est quelque chose de leur faire parler
de vous vous n'êtes pas le seul au monde
on parle des agriculteurs j'entraîne
fermé sans que je mange plus que jamais
très bien les armes par les manifestants
donc je veux réunir à dire que c'est
dommage qu'on puisse aujourd'hui à
berlin cette idée ce qu'il faut c'est
acheter de la viande hachée nos éleveurs
en france qui ont des élevages et des
productions proche c'est-à-dire
favoriser les circuits courts et c'est
comme ça qu'on prête on protégera la
planai les vues des recettes aller au
mans les visas les gens vont mieux comme
vous allez acheter de la viande quand
elle est produite pas loin de chez vous
croyez moi que l'empreinte carbone est
bien moindre que quand vous allez
importer un tas de choses ou même du
soja pour que on remplace les protéines
animales
si vous la question n'est pas de ne plus
manger de viande dans la caisse voilà
j'ai la mienne je continuerai à manger
j'aime ça effectivement comme jean
michel cohen
je suis je compatis cd je sais pas si
vous n'avez pas alors je viens d'avoir
une je dois race ltd jean michel cohen
avec un big mac parsèment la vue et
l'ouïe
non mais on l'a donc mais on note de
l'écologie je suis prêt à faire l'effort
et puis mais je dis de façon égoïste
pour moi aussi parce que j'aurai perçu
comme mangeant toujours de la viande
effectivement il y en a mangé moins
d'intérêt ce que je fais mais je suis
désolé je me sens mieux mais j'ai quand
même besoin de viande ce dîner c'est une
évidence et jamais personne
au nom de quoi que ce soit monsieur la
viande il a un poil magnifique vous dire
je vais même pas vous dire ce que vous
devez faire ou ce que vais pas faire
vous pouvez manger de l'avant mais dans
la version météo extrêmes où ça vient de
moi je parlais justement les
agriculteurs en revanche n'a pas de vie
pas de parents j'ai dû tout là ça c'est
bien moi je vous dis ce que je fais
c'est vous montrer des vidéos de comment
les animaux sont les cadres a déjà fait
parler en francs oui et c'est la même
chose en mêlant mais la connais je sais
pas tout le monde c'est là où est la
région je suis
mais ça qui fait quand j'étais petit je
l'accompagné ils les élever avec respect
eric naulleau qui lave la majorité
toujours mangé tous de la vie en à fond
tous les jours la mauvaise élève et le
cjp rien mais qu'elle sert il donc je
lève toi mais laurent mercier ont la vie
rude on dirait une pomme de terre en
robe de chambre et un vaisseau vague
raconte c'est vrai c'est très courageux
c'est la seule avions pêché de chambre
comme ça non mais vous gagnez une
roquette mais quand on la met sous un
angle un truc gringue arrivée chez relic
aux affaires répète vous blaguez ce plan
le saccage de boucherie et la critique
de la même chose on a condamné le
saccage bouche mais ici on a le droit de
critiquer quand on voit que pour
satisfaire la demande
les animaux sont abattus dans des
conditions effroyables sont élevés dans
des conditions effroyables et qu'on
multiplie les accords de libre échange
pour faire venir du goût du monde des
bleus qui sont élevées sans aucun
contrôle en tout cas pas des contrôles
aussi stricts que ceux qui sont imposées
aux agriculteurs français et européens
en effet le bon sens et puisque vous
avez dit sur l'amazone il était va
également dans ce sens le bon sens et
quand même de réduire la consommation de
viande ce qui est plutôt bon pour
l'assemblée on arrive à harry reid m'a
la question la question c'est une
question qui tend à nous dire est ce que
on doit sortir de l'excès est ce qu'on
doit être un peu dans la régulation et
la modération ou est-ce qu'on doit
continuer effectivement dans une forme
de surproduction de viande et de
consommation devient de la réponse est
effectivement faut aller vers la
modération et c'est un enjeu écologique
mais c'est un jeu aussi de santé
publique ne pas simplement économiques
de santé publique à la forme préserve la
planète et si on préserve la planète
[Musique]
c'est un mec orgie s'est fait plaisir à
mon avis ont dormi sur le banc et
vendredi 13 là ça fait trois minutes qu
on est vendredi très attention merci je
vais car inutile mais non pas du tout
d'entre eux doivent aider mais qu'elle
est fondée sur la plaie 17h transition a
fait ils sont appelés c'est que de la
télé tu es pmp btp c'est bon quoi et on
les aura bravo d'ailleurs au cela il est
4h02 hermine
j'aimerais bien sûr petit termine jeudi
c'est un enjeu de santé publique et
c'est un enjeu écologique effectivement
est un peu comme pour l'agriculture
d'ailleurs moi je suis pour qu'on soit
vers plus de modération
l'agriculture intensive c'est une
catastrophe écologique il faut aller
vers une agriculture raisonnée
après moi je pense qu'il faut inviter
pour répondre à la préoccupation de
laurent seillier qui est une
préoccupation juste l'avenir des
agriculteurs
il faut peut-être retrouver ce qu'on
avait avant c'était des exploitations
mixtes
avant tu avais des éleveurs qui étaient
aussi des agriculteurs des agriculteurs
qui étaient aussi des éleveurs
on a scindé les deux de manière bête et
stupide et on n'a fait que des éleveurs
d'un côté que d'agriculteurs de l'autre
or dans l'élevage qui allait chercher le
fumier qui te permettait d'éviter les
pesticides et de pouvoir aussi te
protéger des certains insectes et
aujourd'hui c'est des pesticides qui ont
pris le pas sur le fumier donc je pense
qu'il veut revenir à quelque chose de
beaucoup plus modérée de beaucoup plus
vertueux
et si la société dans laquelle on dit et
je veux dire un téléphone ça peut
aborder des vertus si on utilise de
manière addict de manière excessive
ça va te rendre dingue que la réalité se
reflète dans la modération je suis là je
suis pas en train de défendre le
véganisme que je soit leur part faites
ce que vous voulez moi je suis pour la
modération rapport aux arbitres c'est
parce qu'elle disait le mis la misère
d'un cutter la misère à culteurs ça
passe 40% de vegan végétalien qu'on
décide d'arrêter de manger de l'avion si
les agriculteurs ja du sud c'est à cause
des industriels qui ont fait de
l'élevage intensif qui nous avait bien
un serveur
la grippe a et la grippe bashing c'est
la fnsea qui part de la guye machine
that qui a 100% en train de défendre les
verrines salées la défendre en tout cas
vous savez bien que de propager et la
chose on arrive à des extrêmes à des
destructions de boucherie parce que tout
va ensemble et on arrive aussi à une
diminution de la consommation vous
parliez à une nouvelle image
allez on va regarder ce que pensent les
téléspectateurs sur ce débat etes-vous
pour ou contre eux mangé ses projets et
ses 55 de ses biens voyez vous pas là
vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas du tout
représentatif laurent se veut voilà vous
mais vous auriez mérité daf et la pomme
de terre second thé second départ par
pas mal de nos camarades en tout cas
vous avez été la seule à dire qu'on
trouve efforts d'équilibré laurence qui
a énormément de courage